[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
fear street
part 3 1666
this again is directed by lee yenyak it
is also again written by lee yenyak
also with phil grazidi who also was the
partner on the first film
and we got a third writer for the first
time with kate trephy
shout out to lee yenyak who has directed
these films she followed me on instagram
lee if you're watching hello i hope i'm
saying your last name right so where i
stand so far in this trilogy is that if
you've watched my previous reviews
definitely go check those out but i
thought 1994 was decent
i loved part two 1978 so 16 16 6
had some high expectations for me the
bar was set so high with two and
i got a lot of conflicting emotions
about this film you could see that 1666
is really influenced by the 2015 film
the witch with anya taylor joy
and also of course the crucible you see
that with set costume designs certain
color palettes
and the thing where it's trying to
replicate a lot of these type of period
pieces
is in the accent this yorkshire accent
this is where the biggest issue of this
film comes into play for me
and that is that not everyone here is
consistently doing their accent and it
really is something that will always
take you out of a movie as a viewer and
this is where i struggle with kiana
madeira here who
is a great actress but she is struggling
with this accent throughout
the film she attempts it a lot which i
appreciate but it drops a lot that goes
with ashley zuckerman as solomon good
that even goes
a couple lines here just for the actor
of ben flores who does
josh and that's really frustrating
especially when it's only a couple lines
too right like let's compare for a
second
you look at someone like emily redwater
praised in the last film she's only got
like five lines in this film but you see
she nails the accent perfectly even
small characters
like sam's mother here does a great job
with it but to have people with a lot of
screen time mess it up a lot
and then even i think it's less
impressive the short screen time like
i'm talking about the character josh
just
really phoning in the accent is
frustrating because it's so
important as the viewer to not be taken
out of anything you ever watch and
that's something that will clearly do it
you're just completely taken out of the
moment it's like
you know you have to give that effort as
an actor and actress to sit down if you
have to with a dialect coach for like
a week live with the dialect coach you
know you have to get that perfected
i just know how audiences feel and it's
going to turn a lot of people off fast
where you can get past certain things or
some people had gripes about maybe the
accuracy of a set on one of the pieces
or maybe a use of music
or a word but accents really big one
what i did like as i like that
characters were reflective of their 1994
self that they did similar behaviors
that the character we knew of them and
now they're playing a new character it's
that connection i think that worked well
in this film
i also think the score like every one of
these films has been top-notch that
eerie violin really setting the tone
well and i do think the production
design
and costume design was really good in
1666 in particular now what's tricky too
about
anything that takes place in this olden
time and deals with witches it's got to
be really scary to be effective and
creepy and eerie we only really get that
when we have the pastor miller story and
we get this really good scene with the
eyes on the floor and then you know
certain characters with their eyes out
that was really disturbing i actually
wanted more of that i wanted more of the
eeriness if you're not going to have the
suspense with the slasher in the 1666
part which are used in other films you
got to bring the horror and i don't
think they brought enough of it and
being that it's pastor miller
who in this story is hannah's father
which is really reflective of sam
i wish that in the 1994 timeline we had
actually met sam's dad to make that hit
a little harder and connect because it
did work well having the parent involved
and i think they should have had where
you have dina here okay sarah fear her
dad's involved i wish in 94 they had
both their parents involved and both in
1666 where they kind of split it all
over the place so it didn't really sink
as well and hit as well but would also
frustrate me it's a tall task
too but this movie really is a
continuation of part one and kind of
takes down the importance of part two
just a bit which little disappointing it
didn't really pick up from the momentum
of part two and i think what stopped
that momentum and that feel of
connection to part two was having that
alice isn't even in 1666 number one and
ziggy
and cindy really had no purpose in the
1666 part and
ziggy disappointedly dies really quick
sadie sync was really just put in there
as the preview part at the end of two to
get people to watch three so you kind of
feel
tricked there but story wise you you
feel that ziggy at least should have had
more importance to this part because
she's such a mean player from this
series
one of the strongest parts of this
trilogy and it still stays in this film
is the love story between dina and sam
where you could say hannah and sarah and
how those linked up it was the most
powerful parts besides like i said the
sister story in part two which i think
really was the best written but what was
strange was i think they just
really missed the opportunity where they
had it right in front of them where mad
thomas here who was tommy slater in the
last film he's the one who catches them
kissing right and then he mentions that
to the town people but
why didn't they just ride off that and
have him be the one who makes up the
rumor
about them being with the devil and
laying with the devil and really
connected to them
being gay that would make the town also
go after them so it really hits hard
where
they kind of just made it that peter's
character here decided to make this
rumor up because he was pissed he was
rejected by sam and humiliated or hannah
should we say and it's like
okay great he's one makes rumor but why
that takes away then from the connection
to them being gay and that's part of why
they were hang so
i just don't see how they didn't just
run with mad thomas taking that all in
and seeing them kiss
then using up the reason to call them
you know being with the devil and then
really push that theme
where's some good writing shine though
was when sarah says to hannah that i
don't fear the devil i fear the neighbor
who would accuse me i fear the mother
that would let her daughter hang
i fear union i think that's connected
again to this thematic
theme about them being not accepted and
fighting against it and paying off
through the whole trilogy now right at
the halfway part we're gonna get this
big reveal for the whole series that
sarah fear isn't the witch behind us all
and the mastermind trying to hurt them
so if you're
showing them what happened and that nick
good aka also solomon good
the good tree is behind all this right
which i think worked i think that was an
effective twist
maybe i would have liked to see more
time and explanation to how the nikkor
we met in two
was so loyal to that family tree but it
still works because we know he again
they kind of masked it as the sheriff
thing and that's where his loyalties
lied is in his destiny so i get it but i
did feel like a little bit of that
momentum of the story between him and
ziggy and how he betrayed ziggy kind of
left in this film now this sequence
though in the cave with
solomon chasing sarah aka dina
went on way too long this needed to be
chopped up a bit the movie's already
a little over long at almost an hour and
53 minutes but when you find scenes like
this you feel like you can chop it a bit
because it was long and this is where
even on my second watch again i was
zoning out here it just
kept going and it was a letdown having
the hand was trying to see what this
happened with this hand off of sarah
fear and to have it that we just had a
great reveal with nick good but then you
cut the hand off and it's just in a
simple way he cut her hand off it wasn't
like this big cool thing that caused it
so that was a letdown what did really
work for me though in 1666
the best part besides the moment with
the pastor
in the church and the eyeballs was when
sarah was hanged and
you see the powerful moment between her
and hannah and that dina has connected
this all and that we're seeing sarah
explain it all the montage really worked
well
i thought this whole point of sarah
showing dina was effective
and that it transitioned so well to this
reveal that we're getting 1994
part two now before i jump into you know
my praise for the second half of this
movie where i i did like it much better
when we got 1994 part two
my biggest criticism of this part i've
never seen anything like it so we see
dina's noses bleeding still obviously
right when she touched the hand
and she gets up is running away from the
sheriff with her brother while she's
catching
josh up about everything she's learned i
don't get it
the actress is literally just wiping her
face and like
keeps touching it to wipe like there's
blood there which there visibly isn't
anymore
so it even if there was it's so
distracting i i have not seen a scene
like that in a while where just hand
motions
that should be a thing right away that
you just don't keep that cut in or make
sure when you're filming like hey put
your hand down you know it's
surreal how i was watching i was like
wow very odd and again
maybe i don't know how you really could
have fixed this but seeing nick good he
completely in 1994 now is a chasing
villain
and i wanted a little more into his
character that we had gotten so well
in part two that they would keep up with
that and maybe have a conversation
between him and ziggy that would be more
powerful which they get a little bit but
not much so we get that stranger things
influence really hit here well we're in
the mall i love the set design here i
love the glow paint
i think this all worked really well and
it shows lee yanyik's
super strong skill at suspense and she's
really good with the camera as well
and it gets me excited seeing all these
shady side killers in this final act
again
and it's like kind of this big moment
but it feels like it opens the door for
more films and i don't know about you i
really want to see the milkman get his
own movie
and i'd love to see more than anything
that little boy with the bat i love the
little shot of him i don't know if he's
hitting an old lady or something but i
want to see that story
for sure another thing that was strange
was in the big climax here when
dean is getting chased after nick good
in the cave sam starts choking dina and
we get this very
cheesy moment where the little piano
music plays and she realizes who it is
through their love but i don't even
think this was necessary because if it
was to show her
be the reason she becomes unpossessed
she becomes unpossessed anyway the curse
is lifted
minutes later so i don't think it was
necessary and worth the risk to come off
cheesy there now i really liked seeing
this
good apartment and we see that family
tree painting and that mystery to
this lore that fear street's building
here with the goods i like that really
in the end of the day sarah fear was
good was the first shady cider they're
giving credit for and that stone which
that was awesome i like that dina and
sam have their moment with the burgers
and the kiss that landed really well
and i like they did like an mcu
mid-credit post scene where we get these
mysterious hands grabbing the book of
the devil
and my theory is that's either the
brother may or good or
there's a reason we're introduced really
quick josh on his cast to get signed by
this little girl
and it's a username from his chat room
so
maybe it's her why would they throw her
in there that last minute so i think
they might be setting up maybe someone
in his chat room's actually evil
but as a whole i cannot get over that
1666 part was a huge letdown
and it was the worst half of any of
these movies to me like just
that accent part is so essential and it
was so distracting it took me out from
the minute it started just
inconsistent accents here and i think
part
two 1994 was one of the better halfs of
all these films so that would bring the
score up a bit but again my distaste for
that first half and disappointment and
lack of horror like i said really brings
it down to
a 6.1 for the film as a whole for me and
i'll go ranking-wise i think this was
the worst film but i thought
number one was decent and i loved number
two so having said that i've also would
love to hear your guys opinions what you
thought of this film how you would rank
the films and on top of that i'm going
to be doing
a live let's talk fear street trilogy in
a couple days so you'll see
a notification on my channel for that
make you sure you subscribe so you can
see that and i'll have me have a
discussion with all you guys and you
guys can share your opinions about the
whole trilogy as a whole we'll do that
in a couple days
i also have a really exciting interview
with olivia scott welch who plays sam
and hannah here she is the best it's my
second time interviewing her
and we talk all about the trilogy it's a
really fun time so that will be out if
it's not out right now you're going to
see it pop
up on monday and i already have weather
interviews julia raywald who plays kate
which was so much fun
i have to talk to ryan simkins and i
talked to mccabe sly
i think you guys were going to love all
those interviews i really tried to work
hard in it and
they're awesome guests every single one
of them so as a whole really enjoyed
this series i'm excited for more films
to come
let me know what you guys thought please
subscribe if you really like these
reviews it helps me in so many ways
and if you really like my reviews i can
appreciate the support if you could just
become a member
small donation you got extra perks like
live streams
badges you name it will help me do this
full time one day and please follow me
at steve varley show on twitter
instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time